you chose the Napali Coast and snorkel
tour when you're ready for a new
adventure just click that annotation up
there and it'll take you right back to
the menu oh boy it's like 6 o'clock in
the morning and we are on our way to the
other side of the island
going on an appalling Coast tourists
sense there's a really good chance that
once we get there we're not even gonna
be able to go on the boat it might be
canceled it was the waves so I could be
driving all this way for
we've arrived on time and the boat is
going out okay you little sailors get on
your little sailing hats Bri got your
sailing hat on yeah
I will see it put that's to put it on
we're going to go on oh we have very
large and we'll see how it goes
so how about in there these dolphins
show hosts about the jumpin and spinnin
and
what you doing yeah I just want to say I
definitely started by this Koreans idea
store wall between of Hawaii
I don't want to say National Geographic
is going to be calling me what
like with snorkeling pianist still on
there I was looking for you too but I
found you I had an idea I get my phone
cuz uh Discovery Channel you want to
talk see you back on board
there's our boat